-♪ "A to Z" ♪
♪ "A to Z" ♪
-Explain it to me.
-All right. Here's how it works.
You and I are going to have
a conversation
about our favorite music.
But the catch is that each time
one of us brings up
a new band or musician,
their name has to start with
the next letter of
the alphabet.
We'll go back and forth
to see if you can get
all the way from A to Z.
-Oh, this is fun.
-All right, ready for this?
All right, so,
Rami, "Bohemian Rhapsody"
is a fun movie to make.
You must have
grew up with music.
-I did.
One of the first bands I heard
was AC/DC, from Australia.
Do you know them?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know them a little bit.
I grew up more with the Beastie
Boys and stuff like that.
-Yeah. I love the Beastie boys.
-You do, right?
Yeah, it's good music.
-Yeah, great, great --
This is already going to be
very interesting, isn't it?
-Yeah.
-Oh, speaking of
Beastie Boys,
This is probably just
a total non sequitur,
but Cat Stevens is --
-"Speaking of Beastie Boys..."
-I mean talk
about guys who just
completely reinvented
themselves, because he --
-David Bowie.
-Yes.
-Yeah. Great example.
-Great example.
-Yeah, it really is.
-The song with Queen,
"Under Pressure," is incredible.
-It is a good song.
-And then you have another one
of their contemporaries,
Elton John.
-Oh, we love Elton John.
-Right?
Sure.
-He's up there with Fergie.
-Fergie.
And the Goo Goo Dolls
could just be --
they could be right up there,
as well, right?
-Well, yeah they can.
You know who's underrated?
Herman's Hermits.
-Yes.
-Underrated.
-Very, very.
-Because, yeah, you just don't
hear enough of them,
and I like their songs.
They're all good.
-I think so.
And, you know, when you think
about Herman's Hermits
and Freddie Mercury, another guy
who ripped his shirt off
quite a bit was Iggy Pop, right?
-Did the Herman's Hermits
rip their shirts off?
-You've never seen
Herman's Hermits...
-No, I've never seen that.
Everyone I've enjoyed
always wore their clothes,
including the Jackson 5.
Everyone always
had everything on.
That's the way I like my music.
-Yes, they did.
-Yeah.
-When you have "K" and...
-What's that?
Are you talking about --
-Yes, the -- I can think of
The Killers at this moment.
-Yeah.
-But how am I going
to incorporate this
into a sentence to keep going?
You just keep going,
why don't you?
-You know, I wish there
was rock festivals
when I was growing --
like, from back in the day
that I got to see,
'cause I would love to see
Little Richard.
-Little Richard.
Oh, I mean --
-Who else
would be on the bill?
-I think, you know, anyone that
could sing like a virgin.
Madonna would be great.
-I'd Love to see -- She's great.
-Yeah.
-So is Nas.
-Nas.
Nas was my youth, man.
-Madonna or Nas?
-And Nas.
But if we really want to
throw it back,
I think Nas really loved
Otis Redding.
Did you know that?
-Really?
-Yeah.
-He didn't like
Peter, Paul and Mary?
I mean, what's his problem?
-No.
-What's his problem?
-He was also a big fan of
the obvious,
Questlove.
You can not talk about Questlove
without talking about --
-Yeah, without Questlove,
there would be no Roots.
-Yes!
And without Roots,
there would be no soul.
And that's not a band,
but I'm going to
keep it going, baby.
-Yeah.
-Or Nina Simone is someone that
they definitely drew from, yes?
-Well, Nina Simone,
but, I mean, he plays drums.
Tito Puente,
you know, stuff like that.
-Oh, it's all full circle.
And, of course, you know,
a band that is iconic
for playing everything
together is U2.
-They're known for
playing things together.
That is correct.
-Yes, they are a band
that plays instruments.
-"Do you guys want to see
people play together?
You've got to go check out U2."
-They are the ones.
-Yeah, or The Verve Pipe.
-The Verve Pipe, yeah.
Or...Who?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Who is a good question.
-Yeah, because
there's a great punk band
with John Doe called X.
-Yes. Punk-rock band.
-The Punk-rock band.
-Yes. And back to that band
that plays everything together,
if you spell out the name
of the band,
it would be You2, Y-O-U.
[ Cymbal crash ]
-You want to go get some beers
and go see ZZ Top?
-I love ZZ Top! Yeah!
-That's what I'm talking about.
Rami Malek, everybody!